إنه يحب التقاط الصور
التي يجب أن تتذكرها أوبتى هو
صبي يبلغ من العمر ست سنوات أنشأه إكسبو
ولذا فهو يدور حول الاستمتاع
بالتفاعل مع
الأطفال الآخرين وأيضًا كونه نوعًا من
الترفيه والمرح للبالغين.
Opti هو أول روبوت تميمة  من أي وقت مضى
في حدث ضخم
لتكون قادرة على التفاعل مع الزوار كل يوم
للقيام برقصات متزامنة للزوار
وأن تكون حقًا مقدمة
للروبوتات ليس فقط للأطفال
ولكن أيضًا للبالغين لكي
يشعروا بما يشبه التفاعل  مع
روبوت مستقل
وله وظائف وقدرات ذكاء اصطناعي
[موسيقى] ،
فإن ميزات opti تجعله ممكّنًا للذكاء الاصطناعي
ولكن في الوقت نفسه
يسهل الوصول إليه ، إنه ودود للغاية ، ينجذب الجميع إلى اختياره
من لون مظهره
الجماليات هي ملامح الوجه ، كل
هذه الأشياء هي التي تتيح إمكانية الوصول إليها ،
يتحرك محسن [الموسيقى] في جميع الأنحاء من خلال إنشاء خريطة ثلاثية الأبعاد
حوله باستخدام lidar
و w  إنه يتجنب
الاصطدام
بالأشياء عن طريق مستشعراته ، لذلك لديه مستشعرات في كل
مكان
لديه اكتشاف تصادم حتى لا
يصطدم بأي شخص
أثناء تحركه ، ينشط الزر الموجود
أعلى رأسه ميزات مختلفة للوجه
وفي
بعض الأحيان ينشط أيضًا روتينًا بسيطًا
للرقص  يمكن للأشخاص رؤيته في
كثير من الأحيان ، فسترى أن
الضغط على رأسه
سيعطيك حركات ذراع حتى تتمكن من التقاط
صور معه ،
ما رأيناه هو أن الناس ينجذبون
إلى opti وخاصة الصغار
الذين يريدون الاقتراب  يريدون
لمسه
، يريدون معرفة ما
يفعله ،
إنه أمر بديهي جدًا بالنسبة
للأطفال الأصغر سنًا الذين اعتادوا على نشأتهم مع أجهزة
iPad التي اعتادوا على نشأتها باستخدام
شاشات تعمل باللمس ، لذا فهم على ما يرام
آلة ونرى ما الذي يفعله
تحريك الذراعين ،
يفعل الرأس كما يفعل الزر في الواقع
، وبالتالي يكون لدينا
سحب فوري للاختيار مما رأيناه